think may I I think you just fought the
right what about if my friend they're
gonna get to know that that's the
difference
you can't really control who you like or
who you fall for but you can control how
you deal with the situation or how you
operate or how you choose to move
forward okay I've got questions
when you found out about the body count
where you repulsed
um I wouldn't say repulse no because I
just don't really get that surprised in
this day and age like you know the
figures
did you go there no why not
because it it never came about well if
you come about where you're still gone
with the three figures yeah yeah yeah
I think maybe Medicare undo their
biology they're biologically
predisposition to want to spread their
seed but they're also biologically
predispositioned to want to want to
ensure paternity so like historically if
a girl slept around they don't know if
the kid she's having is his and that
even still happens nowadays like you see
videos all the time where this dude
that's been raising a kid for 10 years
finds out this kid isn't his and girls
can do that legally there's no
ramifications where if guys don't play
child support they go to jail but a girl
can trap a guy and crazy some more he
made a whole career off that real [__]
yeah and so like guys can't undo how
they feel about it I don't think like
that automatically if she has a high
body count and if she is in a
relationship she actually you know love
the man she been with she's gonna sleep
automatically with someone else so
easily that doesn't honestly we should
like distinguish between when you single
are you afraid to do whatever you wish
and when you are in our relationship so
it doesn't mean you're gonna be not
loyal
do you know what I mean like okay it's
more likely your habits are who you are
why you need to label someone just
because yeah it's based on your it's not
based on your action so it's the same
for men
can actually is actually allowed to have
high body count so what I what I
supposed to think if I'm actually going
to marry the man they gonna cheat on me
but women don't women women don't care
because I'm I'm a woman and I can't as
well no no so women women don't care you
don't see girls lining up to date Drake
and saying oh no his body counts too
high how will I go like no no but but
but the opposite of that Brittany Grant
graner Griner whatever her name is like
guys are like oh Jesus Christ oh no no
no no no yeah because and she's
beautiful but right now and your how
your habits like make up who you are so
if you've been doing something for a
decade how like just like if a guy
cheated on every single girl before you
he's probably gonna cheat on you too duh
personally for me if if a guy's body
count is like the three figures I'd be
just as disgusted don't matter if he's
Drake Chris but I don't care I'd be
repulsed to be honest
if it's 50 depending on how old he is
again I'd still feel a bit icky is it oh
yeah no you're gonna be icky would you
want to marry a virgin
I wouldn't mind you wouldn't mind
marrying a virgin you want to like tell
him what to do I wouldn't mind because
it's not
it's not an issue for me if he ticks
every single box and then it turns out
he's a virgin to me I wouldn't I
wouldn't be fast could you name could
you name five of your boxes
name five of my boxes yeah so ambitious
God-fearing like prayerful
um
loyal as well
funny sort of sense of humor and
I can't think of a fifth one when you
say ambitious is there a dollar amount
no ambitious like driven wanting
something for himself and not just so if
he's making how old are you so you're 31
35 35 how old would you date
the oldest I would do yeah probably 40.
so if he's 40 and he still makes 30 000
I don't know the conversion like 30 000
US Dollars which would be like 20 20.
like 20 000 um 20 000 pounds would you
be cool with that he's 40 he said time
to get there
if he's if he's trying to get somewhere
and he's not just what if he gets what
if he gets nowhere
well because I'd I'd sense that he's not
ambitious and it would put me off right
but I think like a lot of times it's
kind of disingenuous to guys because
girls will say there's no price but you
you have one in your head and there is a
price he there has to be working towards
that like towards it or there but if he
doesn't get there within a certain
amount of time your ghost you're gone no
but you can't really put a time frame on
I'm giving you a time to become
successful but no I'm saying um to want
to get there and actively trying to get
there does that make sense right you
might not know it like con like you
might not have thought about it but like
in some level you're not gonna date a
bum forever so if he if he's well I
wouldn't have if he's a bum and he's not
ambitious I wouldn't be attracted to him
yeah yeah but I'm saying there's a
there's a doll there's a minimum dollar
so okay would you date a guy that's
homeless with no job I wouldn't meet a
guy that's homeless of my job where
would I meet you pass him every day but
why would I approach
me or how would that work right but I'm
saying you there's a minimum requirement
you have nice not just related to like
is that a bad thing no it's not a bad
thing I don't think I don't think we
should date bombs yeah I'm saying like
you're avoiding the question what was
the question what's the minimum amount
of money you need a guy to make
I don't know more than me I don't know
it's the same as me or more okay what's
roughly you don't have to
I don't want to say my how much I make
but the same as me or more that's you
can't make less than you right basically
yeah okay why not well I'm not saying he
can't but I would prefer I'm saying what
I prefer is if he was the same level as
me or make him more if he's making less
a bit less and actively trying to
progress with Vinny's career then
there's nothing wrong with that okay I'm
just ask something he said about the
boxes
what are your boxes and it was the
Virgin you said you'd take on a virgin
virgin
no woman ever says sex
if it was a man wouldn't that be one of
your boxes
because I've only takes your boxes yeah
as a man wouldn't sex be one of your top
boxes I'm just asking as in would I
marry a virgin
no are you getting yourself boxes you
know you said every man ever woman takes
all your boxes right isn't sex one of
your boxes
could you have a happy relationship
without having that box sticks without
having sex or without having good sex
good sex
yeah I could still have a pretty
successful relationship not me yeah
I don't believe you oh yeah I mean look
I don't
mean boxes no no no because I'm saying
everybody's talking about oh I want to
be nicer compatible but you won't know
that until you have sex with him
that's why when women say they want to
have a virgin to me I teach in a
Manhattan yeah I mean because I ain't
got time if I'm a virgin he's a virgin
fine but I'm not gonna go and pick up a
virgin
F6 is one of my boxes and sex is one of
my boxes it should be a man's box too
because if you're not getting good sex
from your woman go elsewhere same here
for women I'm sorry but how could that's
why they got seckless marriages out
there yes how can you be having like you
be oh yeah I'm happy because sex is not
one of my boxes she knows that sex ain't
one of your boxes the window six is gone
what are you gonna do then say Oh but I
like her personality
so every question do you think it's fair
for women to expect monogamy from men if
they gave their best years to another
man foreign